outside her home Nora sublaban shouts
the criminals have evicted her and given
it to settlers from abroad
Israeli soldiers cordoned off this
narrow Alleyway in Akbar al-haladiya in
the heart of occupied East Jerusalem
they pushed their way into the sublaban
family's home and evicted them
people have gathered to support the
family the mother has lived here for
nearly seven decades
I was born in this house it holds all my
beautiful memories before the death of
my mother my childhood with my mother
after her death I became a mother age
13. I raised two brothers in this house
the family say the landlord of this poem
is linked to a settler movement that
wants to reshape the identity of the old
city they say they expelled her on the
grounds before her birth the owner of
the property was Jewish that's legal
under Israel's absentee property law
passed in 1950 it allows Jews to reclaim
the property that's historically Jewish
owned
Palestinians cannot do the same
it's a mechanism in which the states and
and settler organization are using this
discriminate discriminative laws in
order to evict Palestinians from their
homes and take over their homes and and
develop them as new settlements while
we're filming Israeli settlers
surrounded what was a protest held in
solidarity with the supla bands and
anger turned to scuffles
the mother of the supplement family says
she is hopeful that she will see her
house this house once again but this
kind of influence isn't unusual
according to the UN mum 218 Palestinian
families in occupied East Jerusalem are
under eviction orders likely to lose
their homes and lands
her son says the settlers are stealing
and taking more than the family's home
my mother will be coming to Al-Aqsa to
pray and cry because she can no longer
access the house where she was born and
where her mother has passed away where
all of her siblings grew up and where
some of us also grew up this is stealing
not just a home it's stealing our
memories it's stealing our past it's
stealing our praise in Jerusalem
as the protesters dispersed more Israeli
settlers entered the house before the
family could remove their furniture
they raised the Israeli flag from the
balcony from where the supply bands once
watched over Al-Aqsa mosque
Laura Khan Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem